so this year's r slash place event is
officially over and it was a banger
reddit's giant collaborative artwork had
everything national flags tributes
insane factions destructive entities
whose sole existence is to destroy
but then there are some gaming gems you
might have missed their cs go with the
impressive time-lapse spray pattern that
eventually got among us the dota boys
managed to come together and stake its
place smash got a small but very clean
piece and among us was literally
everywhere and everything
and like i mean everything oh my wait
wait oh oh my god
i see them now
what
halo made an appearance with a master
chief mural apex legends made it rest in
peace reckful tarik stamped his corner
along with a portrait of jet even crew
esports made it along with a popular
rhythm game osu and remember while
everyone built these masterpieces canada
struggled to get their together
but the butt i imagine they that would
have stayed